it's something I encourage a lot of
entrepreneurs to think about I think a
lot of people they will go from their
full-time job quit they have very meager
savings and suddenly they're like this
has to work well now you've put yourself
in a bad position either start it while
you have a full-time job do it on the
side and don't tell me you don't have
time you have time and the second thing
is build up your savings your savings
are going to give you the runway or the
flexibility to try different things a
business is not easy especially going
from zero to one it's pretty hard and if
you're under a time crunch where you
have like two months of cash left you're
gonna start making bad decisions need
motivation what's your top 10 of believe
Nation Hey Kevin Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I was making 300 bucks a month
I quit on my business partner and the
thing that saved me was studying the
stories of super successful
entrepreneurs so I hope that this story
today helps give you the motivation you
need because I still needed to myself so
today let's learn from one of the best
ramid Sethi and my take on his top 50
rules for Success enjoy
the average of the five people you're
surrounded with that is a very powerful
idea and instead of closing the door on
the people you hang out with why not
open the door to some new people why not
find people who go to your conference
for example or who are on my site people
who are ambitious who have gone through
these programs and say you know what can
we set up a weekly check-in it could be
five minutes it could be over text but
let's set up this check-in and just say
what'd you want to do last week did you
execute why or why not every week 9 A.M
Monday let's do it that's how you
suddenly meet a group of people who are
unapologetically ambitious and that will
change everything for you because
instead of having to drag people to
these self-development conferences and
they say that's weird I don't want to do
it the people you actively seek out
gonna be like yeah I'm in let's do it
let's do it yeah that's powerful yeah so
find the new communities that you can
have these conversations with yeah and
don't cut everyone out of your life but
just start having those conversations
with people that are more aggressive
yeah like do you know what I told people
to do on my Instagram account so I told
people it's important to find other
people who support you a lot of you are
waiting around for some like millionaire
to fall out from the sky and invite you
to their private group it's never going
to happen never instead why don't you
start it yourself and I said go into my
comments write who you're looking for
and then invite someone to join you like
that you don't need to wait no one's
coming to rescue you it's not a Disney
movie nobody's coming it's only you so
take control and go find someone and
then build that together so
how do you go from a group of people who
complain about a 4.95 eBook to a group
of people who are delighted to pay
tens and tens of thousands of dollars
how do you create a community of thirty
thousand loyal happy customers these are
consumers these are people like you and
me they're in this room
and they are spending thousands of
dollars once and then doing it again and
again and in fact when they buy their
top criteria not even their top five
criteria is about price we do a ton of
research we collect hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of data points
this is one we ask people why did you
not join our course
look at the comments it's too expensive
another pivotal moment here
the world will try to drag you down in
price Silicon Valley will try to drag
you down in price and say nobody would
pay for that people don't pay for insert
blank topic here and if they do they'll
only pay five bucks a month
well we don't believe that we actually
believe that there's there's room in the
market to be the best and we mean build
the best products
select the best customers and service
them in the best way we have no
intention of playing in the five dollar
fifty dollar hundred dollar market I'd
rather give away our content than play
in that market so how do we do this the
key Insight I Learned was don't just
listen to the first response because
that's politically correct that's what
they'll tell you but when you build
something that is so good it solves such
a big burning pain in their life then
price is a mere triviality
and if you think about it we all this we
intuitively know this we all have
something in our life that we would pay
anything for maybe it's
um a business class ticket for your mom
to come visit you so she can stretch out
her legs right maybe it's a beautiful
leather jacket maybe it's a bag of chips
you just love these chips whatever we
all have something we pay anything for
and the same can be true for your
products as well there are some people
around us who just seem like they are
born with natural confidence you know
who I'm talking about they're super
smooth super confident they always know
the right thing to say
think about President Obama
seems like a smooth guy think of one of
his famous yes we can rally speeches not
being political here just talking about
his oratorical skills
what do you notice about how he speaks
powerful
he's decisive he speaks slowly and
almost never stumbles or stutters
his points are clear
and they're to the point
he's the epitome of confidence when it
comes to a speaker on stage
so when you look at somebody like him
it's very easy to assume that he has
some innate ability that he was born
with either you have it or you don't
but the truth is confidence is a skill
and President Obama just like all
confident people built that skill
he practiced it over a lifetime so
here's a simple example of how you can
control your confidence in less than 20
seconds
take something you routinely say like
what you did this weekend
and change the way you say it I want you
to channel
your inner super confident person it
could be Barack Obama it could be Susan
Sarandon it could be whoever you want
don't focus on who it is don't even
worry about what you say instead focus
on changing how you say it
sit up straight
speak slowly
and imagine what you're saying is
incredibly important because the people
listening want to hear it
let me show you an example a little
before and after
uh
uh I can't even remember I mean I think
it was pretty good it was actually
pretty crazy but uh I just went to a
movie and saw some friends you know the
usual I guess
now let's compare the after
we had a great weekend I was with the
kids on Saturday
then Michelle and I caught a Broadway
show and finished the night at that new
sake bar downtown
now would you notice notice first that
I'm intentionally using someone else to
role play this really lets us get into
play acting without worrying about our
own life our own Saturday oh maybe I
don't have as cool of a life as going to
a sake bar don't worry about that
all we're doing here is working on our
delivery remember nobody sees inside of
you they don't see how confident you are
how much work you spent practicing all
they see is the way you answer a
question or the way you sit when you're
talking to them
so when it comes to confidence
confidence can actually come from the
outside in not just from the inside out
which is what everybody tells you so
instead of waiting for it to just
magically appear where's my confidence
where is it we're actually changing our
Behavior
something everyone can do and we're
letting the confidence follow the
external influence is the internal and
once you master this concept you can
apply it to a lot more than just how you
speak and how you sit
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there when anyone says you know I bought
a business class ticket notice the
almost instinctive reaction it's like uh
you know what a show off and all these
other things that come on with it and I
want to challenge people I have this
principle I call the D to C principle
and it instead of uh being derisive and
saying oh so stupid that's ridiculous I
would never do that I actually want to
encourage everyone to be C curious why
would a guy like Lewis intentionally
spend money on a business class ticket
and he he earns good money he has a lot
of options he must know something that I
don't and I want to understand why so
from D to C and if you start to take
that perspective especially on high
earners and how they spend their money
all of a sudden you stop saying that's
ridiculous or if I had a million dollars
I would never do that instead you say
why did that person spend on it and I
want to know maybe I don't agree maybe
you know you become a multi-millionaire
and you don't want to spend on business
class you just don't care but it's it's
interesting that you do it and I'd like
to know more yeah if you go to the site
I will teach you to be rich
you can see the names of the products
but you can't buy why because I don't
want you to go and just look at the
course and just say do I like this or
not do I feel like it's not a pack of
gum these are works of art that we spent
years and millions of dollars building
and testing and so what I want to do
instead of just trying to get money
quickly I want to build a relationship
so the only thing you can do you can
read 12 years of free material you can
look at our thousands of YouTube videos
but if you want to know more then I want
to send you free material through our
email list and so you can see there's
lots of places to sign up to get tons of
bonus material now if you do that
suddenly you and I have a relationship
and I can send you emails and on and on
so we have you know many hundreds of
thousands of people who are on our email
list and they get emails from us
four or five times a week isn't that a
lot yeah well a lot of people I've heard
that I email more than people's
girlfriends boyfriends moms dads I say I
love it because our emails break all the
rules they're really long people say oh
nobody has time make it quick wrong if
you have something interesting to write
people will read 20 Page long emails and
we don't allow people to buy until the
time is right when the time is right we
open up our course you can join if you
choose if not that's totally fine who
here has felt some sort of rejection in
the last 30 days with your business
come on don't me
everybody does and you know the crazy
part is they won't tell you the truth
they'll never say uh you spent the last
four years of your life building a photo
sharing app and the truth is I don't
really care if my photos aren't
organized they'll never tell you that
just be like I think the price is a
little high
remember that five dollar ebook I
created
I had people who were like ramit love
the ebook but I don't trust PayPal but I
do trust the U.S postal service so if
you could set up a PO Box I would in
fact I'll buy two copies and like naive
ramit in 2006 I was like okay so I
actually set up a P.O box and I was like
waiting like where's my bushel full of
checks and over the course of an entire
year I received one check for 4.95
don't make my mistakes
the thing is they'll never tell you why
they'll never tell you why so I want to
show you how we handle those here's a
script I'd like to show it to you this
is from a student of ours who applied
for a program he was accepted and then
he didn't join let me read it to you hi
Karthik I noticed you were interested in
testing blah blah blah and you filled
out the application but you didn't sign
up how come the course is closed now but
I just wanted to reach out and find out
what's up
so this is written very intentionally
um first people don't like to be told
hey you said you were going to do
something and then you didn't do it they
don't like it but we still want to find
the answer to our question
um so we did a couple things in this
email we've tested this one we kept it
really short two it's super
conversational notice the phrases how
come or let me know what's up sometimes
we say out of curiosity we're not saying
you know we're not being super corporate
about it and then third we have to be
really clear we're not trying to sell in
fact the course is now closed we we
cannot collect your money we don't want
it
we get massive responses
so if you have had people who are on
your email list or in your customer base
they have not bought something from you
you're sitting on a gold mine the type
of answers we get from this are amazing
they'll say things like well I'd love to
join but you know course looks awesome
but I'm in Australia and I can't fly to
New York we're like dude it's an online
course
but that's not their fault it's our
fault for not communicating that or we
get people who say this course looks
amazing but it's really expensive and I
can't convince my husband or wife to buy
into it that's actually really valuable
so now we can add that to our FAQ so we
collect these data points at every stage
of the customer experience before the
product in the product if they refund
etc etc I can't tell you enough you have
to listen to the customer why is it hard
for us to talk about money why is it
scary why don't we talk about it enough
with our friends our family
why is that there's one great study
showing people would rather talk about
their sex lives than their amount of
credit card debt I love that I think
that's totally true it's true 100 and
think about what money means uh it means
that you were successful in this culture
and I'm here you know no people know me
as the I will teach you to be rich guy
and I have always said money is an
important but small part of living a
rich life just because you make more or
less doesn't mean we're better friends
not at all has nothing to do with that
uh but it is important for people to be
in control of their money whether
they're making 15 an hour or fifteen
thousand dollars an hour and there are
people I know who make that so uh that
just simply shows are you in control of
your life at whatever level you are it's
embarrassing for people they're never
taught this and then suddenly they
graduate and they're supposed to know
what tax withholding is and what a 529
and 401k and all this crazy stuff is
nobody taught it to them so uh my goal
here the reason I'm talking about this
is for people to feel more confident
about their money for them to take
control and for them to stop being
afraid and listening to random people
giving them advice who are your money
mentors who's been your mentors you know
uh I've studied most of the greats and I
read their stuff I think it's absolutely
fascinating to know from different types
of investors different types of personal
finance personalities but the people
that influence me most come from the
world of psychology they come from
different worlds so we have a we have an
amazing Professor BJ Fogg one of my
mentors Brian wansick at Cornell who
wrote an amazing book mindless eating
which is so close to money it's just
about food all these guys cialdini of
course who teach us about the true
theoretical psychology of why we do what
we do those are the people who actually
influence me the most I actually want to
make the case against extreme frugality
everybody everywhere you turn you hear
people telling you what you can't do
with your money no lattes no jeans no
vacations save it up in a little
treasure box and then one day when you
can't even see anymore then you'll be
able to take the greatest vacations of
your life who wants to live like that I
would rather you set your automatic
savings goals you set your automatic
investing goals and then you take the
rest of your money your guilt free money
and you spend it extravagantly on the
things you love one way very simple when
you go to the grocery store maybe you
buy a bunch of pre-cut vegetables now
when I was growing up my mom thought
this was a huge waste of money I now
think it's a great use of money because
it buys back my time another thing you
can do a lot of people live in New York
hire a dog walker you have a dog you may
not have time to walk that dog in the
middle of the day boom dog walker done
and then as you become even more
successful or more strapped for time
there are even more ways that you may
want to spend your money you may want to
hire an assistant to help plan your
travel you may want to spend for a
business class flight because when you
arrive you're getting straight to work
these are all different ways that you
can be thinking of buying back your time
as a general rule of thumb I want you to
be saving five to ten percent of your
take-home income and I want you to be
investing 10 of your take-home income if
you do that you're on a good track and
that means that the rest of your money
after your fixed expenses like your rent
or your mortgage is guilt-free money I
didn't ever start the site to generate
Revenue so it was a Blog in fact I
didn't generate a cent of revenue for
about three years and I didn't put ads I
didn't do anything because I didn't want
people to think that this was
some way for me to make a quick Buck I
mean the name of the site alone it
already kind of makes you like who's
this weird guy
So eventually
um about three years after starting it
I said I want to just try
selling something on the side I'd never
sold anything online and this was late
2006. so there weren't a lot of people
selling a ton of stuff online but I said
let me put together a small ebook it was
about 30 pages
and I sold it for
4.95 and I I absolutely love this
because first of all that number is so
small and now you know we have courses
that sell for over twelve thousand
dollars and and yet that five dollar
ebook was the most scared I've ever been
about selling anything so remember I've
been writing for free for three years
um probably three to five times a week I
had a community that was really loyal so
these people were there were like
hundreds of comments on posts
and I'm like oh my God I'm gonna post
this so I post the ebook is a good ebook
and it was beautifully designed
and I was afraid that people would call
me a sellout that people would say oh so
this is a trick you've just been
building this up so you can sell and and
actually that's exactly what happened
um I had people and the comments are
still live you can go back and look at
it where people said oh I will teach me
to be rich and oh so clearly you've
jumped the shark all these horrible
things and as an entrepreneur that
really hits you in the gut because I
felt betrayed that I had been doing this
for free for years and I felt that
people were questioning my ethics that
why would I play a three-year trick
right and just all these yeah and also
when you think about it is selling
really tricking someone no I don't
believe it is but back then I was scared
to sell I didn't think anyone would buy
I was selling from my heels which means
I was almost apologizing right so many
entrepreneurs do that oh I'm afraid so
what am I going to do I'm going to lower
my price yeah that'll make them love me
and and of course all of those things
were wrong what stood out to me though
was that while there were all these loud
vocal minority commenters who were
worthless they were never going to buy
no matter what right there was a quiet
group of people who were buying and I
could see the numbers they were buying
they were sending me really positive
emails they were opening my emails more
so I could see the math
and I was kind of confused how come
there's this loud vocal minority of
complainers and then there are these
people who are actually loving it and
saying what's next right so that's when
I made the decision that I didn't
understand what was going on but there
was something going on here yeah and I
want to figure it out and over the next
three years I dived deep into the
psychology of selling
into how to create world-class products
pricing basically how to create value
that people are so happy to pay that
price is a mere triviality what's a few
simple things that they should be doing
right now to have a checklist to do
before the end of the year to then Crush
for a whole 12 months moving forward all
right I'm gonna give you something
called the latter of personal finance
which tells you where your money should
go okay this is just step by step put
your money here and if you want to know
all the details about it you can check
out the system so it's in the book too
though it's in great detail in the book
got it all right so
if you've got some money lying around
what should you do with it first of all
if you've got a 401k match at work you
should Max that out that's free money
take advantage of it and if you're not
sure what that means go to your HR
person and say does this company match
any 401K contributions if they say yes
do what I said uh next if you've got
Debt Pay It Off pay it off aggressively
you know what's interesting is that most
people in debt who I talk to don't
actually know how much they owe and
that's shocking you would think of
course they would know no they don't
because who wants to proactive they're
dead all day yeah and just feel bad
about it but you know what you feel much
better when you have a plan and the
number one question I ask folks uh when
they tell me they have debt I say number
one do you know how much you owe they
never do number two for the rare people
who say you know fifteen thousand or
seventy thousand whatever I say what is
your debt payoff date you can actually
plug it in you can pay uh plug in a debt
payoff calculator online
you can map it all out and you will be
able to know the exact month your debt
will be paid off based on how much
you're spending right now based on how
much you're contributing to that debt
payoff now you will be able to see that
if you add an extra 50 bucks a month or
100 bucks a month that thing will
actually oftentimes shorten by years
because of the interest it doesn't
matter if it's going to take you three
months or four years to pay off your
debt it doesn't matter to me what
matters is that you know the date okay
so that's number two pay off any debt
you've got three if you've got money
left over uh go to your Roth IRA and if
you can Max that out that's a great tax
advantaged account it grows tax deferred
is that right yeah yeah okay so
um so that's three that's three okay
it's actually post tax money and then
four if you still got money you're going
to go to back to your 401k which is uh
another tax advantaged account you're
going to Max that out if you still got
money
you're going to create a non-taxable
non-retirement account and just put your
money in there now there's a few other
wrinkles to this there's hsas available
there's also your emergency fund that's
talked about in the book and all these
things they're details but that just
shows you when you've got money this is
where you go there's a structured way of
thinking about it a ladder towards
financial success exactly and if you
follow the steps it's almost like the
like a waterfall it just goes from step
one to step two to step three and your
money's going where it needs to go
automatically and you will feel great
you'll feel great which is so important
and also you're going to look at your
accounts and see that's going down
investment and savings are going up and
all of a sudden you wake up six months
from now and you're like oh my God I
didn't realize I have that much saved in
my savings account that's because of the
decision you made today after running
this business for 12 years
I think I learned I think my beliefs
changed
um I believe now that the world will
always try to get you to be vanilla the
world wants you to do everything like
them they want you to lower your prices
the world will pull you down uh they
want you to make your website look like
everybody else's easy fast
cure
and the minute you do it
they abandon you
the world wants you to look exactly like
it and the minute you do it they will
abandon you I think that there are
definitely
systemic problems when it comes to
things like inequality when I think it
comes to things like student loan debt
yes those are problems and there needs
to be a lot of work done on those and we
can simply look at history to see how
crazy tax rates are compared to where
they've been historically or how crazy
student loan debt is compared to where
it was historically but whenever I hear
someone who starts complaining about the
large-scale societal problems I just
have one question I say do you invest in
your 401k and it's one thing to talk
about systemic problems and we should
talk about them and Tackle them but the
best thing we can do for ourselves is to
focus on what we can control and that's
what I believe that's why I'm here some
people work on systemic problems I'm
here to help people one-on-one with
their money and their psychology
yeah that that to me is a a very
interesting and Powerful approach I come
out of the same way I was giving a talk
at Google and there was an
African-American gentleman in the front
row and basically the question was like
is it harder for me and my answer was
yes that seems pretty apparent but now
what so you can go try to tackle that
systemic problem and I'm super glad that
there are people who are wired for that
yeah but for me I'm always like what can
I do right now today because when you're
dealing with huge systemic problems
you're basically you're doing something
amazingly altruistic for the Next
Generation but the odds of you being
able to reap the benefits of that are
pretty slim yeah yeah I agree and I
think that when you can start to take
control and make one step after another
for example for people who are in debt
it's so interesting when people write me
about how to get out of debt over 90 of
them don't know how much they owe so if
you don't have know how much you owe I
understand that why would you want to
open up the emails and the bills it's
you don't know what's inside but you
know what it's bad but the first step to
doing that to paying it off is to open
it up confront reality get real and then
make a plan and all of those things can
be done in and of yourself without
regards to what's going on outside your
house or outside your email inbox in
college you get interested in finance
how did you start getting that interest
another another accident which was I
took that first scholarship I got and I
invested it in the stock market so they
had written the check to me this is 1999
2000 I take that money I think I know
what investing is which I don't and I
lose half of that immediately that's not
a good thing to do with your college
scholarship when I was like oh man and I
started studying personal finance now
finance and personal finance very
different things if we look outside the
street we see investment bankers they
have nothing to do with money that you
and I operate with on a daily basis so I
started reading and I saw all these
experts say saying these These Old
chestnuts we've heard over and over keep
a budget don't spend money on lattes
never go on never do anything with your
money just sit at home like a Hermit
yeah and at the same time I was studying
human psychology I was studying
persuasion I was studying all these
facets of human behavior at Stanford and
I just realized like that book The
Emperor has no clothes I realized that
all this expert advice
didn't actually work so when people say
keep a budget great in theory nobody
keeps a budget when people say don't
spend money on lattes great in theory
nobody listens to it in fact I don't
even want to listen to it like I go out
I want to go out I want to buy a round
of drinks for my friends I want to be
able to go in a taxi if it's really hot
outside or whatever the case may be yeah
and the experts spent the last 50 years
telling us all the things we can't do
with our money and so I started
developing a philosophy of what you can
do and living a rich life and that
doesn't mean putting it all in a savings
account and just counting your pennies
every day I think it actually means
living life sometimes I learned that
people just aren't ready to buy and
that's just the way it goes
um like we had people that have been on
our list for six years they've seen some
of these products be launched like seven
14 times and then one day they'll just
buy randomly and I see it come across my
dashboard I'm like what is this so I'll
email them hey notice you've you know
joined finally after seven years what's
up and they're like they'll tell us the
most interesting things they'll be like
oh well I tried to do it on my own it
didn't work so I'm finally ready or oh I
paid off my debt or or just because and
so my key lesson from that was just to
be patient if you've put the right
process into place if you've selected
the right customers if you've built the
best products you have the best
marketing our philosophy is it's just a
matter of time so we grew up with these
things I call invisible scripts and
these are the scripts that are beliefs
that are so powerful
we don't even realize that they're
they're around us that's why they're
invisible so a classic one in America is
the American dream is buying a house
where did that come from and in fact
there's all these phrases that people
use like uh you're throwing money away
on rent they don't make more land you
know and on and on if you really
deconstruct that and you actually run
the numbers you might discover that
actually buying a house is often not the
best investment and this is super
counterintuitive people get really mad
because real estate is religion in
America but if you actually dive in deep
you might discover wow there's a lot of
parties who want me to spend a ton of
money that's why for example I could buy
today but I rent and when people hit
they're like wait I thought the I will
teach you to be rich guys rich so wisely
they get very confused because real
estate is religion you know another
thing that is really common today for
people is there's no way to get ahead
right especially for young people Social
Security won't be around etc etc
and I just don't believe in that I think
if you go on to Reddit or you go on to
these places where it's a it's a lot of
people who are disaffected young people
they create an echo chamber of other
people who want to victimize themselves
then you have a choice do you want to be
reading those threads or like I was
reading the comments on your YouTube
videos I was like these are the best
YouTube comments I've ever seen people
are positive constructive they're
pointing out things they saw in the 32nd
minute of the video meaning they
actually watched the whole thing those
are the kind of people that I want
people to be around so it's not
impossible to make money there's
actually a lot of people making money
it's not impossible to get head pay off
debt even invest and grow there's a lot
of people doing it but if you're
surrounded by people who constantly
complain about how difficult it is and
it's impossible guess what you're going
to absorb those invisible scripts you'll
notice that a lot of these online
entrepreneurs what do they tend to brag
about have you noticed
um number one how much money they make
yeah
yeah number two subscribers how many
subscribers and number three how big
their team is have you ever noticed that
and also number four how little they
work oh I make a million dollars I only
work two days a year okay go f yourself
so so you'll notice that we don't brag
about how much money we make we've
mentioned a couple of times some
remarkable results that we've generated
but we don't go around bragging about
how much money we make we don't brag
about how many people we have we don't
brag about how little we work I work a
lot and so does our team and we love it
I would rather spend our time bragging
about our students results and that's
why you see us putting them front and
center we put their photos we put their
full links to their websites we fly them
into New York and do full case studies
with them very expensive but it's the
right thing to do I'd rather talk about
how we took ordinary people like the
people watching and help them build
massively successful businesses or learn
how to cook or lose weight whatever
I'd rather talk about that than oh look
how many people I have and look at our
budgets how does one become rich in an
environment where there's two percent
treasury rates and unemployment is high
it's difficult to get a job for a young
person how do you do that you know I
think there's a few ways of looking at
it and the first thing I would
consider especially based on psychology
is to focus on the big wins right so the
latte example is bad advice because one
it doesn't work and two it's minutia
saving two or three dollars a day
doesn't really do anything in the grand
scheme of things and it makes us feel
guilty right instead if we get these
five or ten big wins right we never have
to worry about Lattes or the size of our
diet coke ever again for example
starting to invest early getting your
asset allocation right not buying real
estate simply because you think it's the
best investment like so many people
believe if you get these five or ten big
wins right negotiating your salary Etc
you never have to worry about the little
things there is room in the market for
the best
the the things that we do in product
development and growth and customer
service and all the groups that we have
it's about craftsmanship it's about
spending whatever it takes to build the
best product we do test we do a B test
we do all of that but taking the time
because when we launch something we know
that it has to be the best that's how we
honor the students who joined our
programs there's room in the market for
the best don't ever let the market pull
you down you should pull the market up
with you there's two key things that
stop people from moving forward and it
stops them for months years even decades
so the first one is I don't have an idea
oh you don't have an idea so what does
that mean you're just going to wait for
an idea to fall down from the sky well I
don't have an I don't have an idea
either you find an idea and you search
out for it and you generate hundreds of
ideas and then you slice and dice them
and test them so that's number one the
idea that you and a lack of idea is
stopping you that should never be the
the case there are ways to generate
ideas and then test them for
profitability that's what we talk about
on our site the second thing is I don't
have any time please give me a break you
don't have any time yes you do so it's
almost like if you say I don't have time
that's a politically correct way to say
this is not a priority because no one
can ever disagree with you and say hey
you actually have time it's sort of very
Politically Incorrect to say but if you
if somebody says I don't have time left
yeah I'm really busy too man so don't
say that when you start using phrases to
describe yourself in a negative way it
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy so
like I used to say I'm just a skinny
Indian guy I used to weigh 50 pounds I
was very skinny I was 50 pounds skinnier
than I am now and I was like I'm just a
skinny Indian guy can't put on any
muscle wrong I just wasn't eating enough
and I wasn't working out but because I
said that it became part of my identity
So when you say I don't have time I'm so
busy I or the worst I'm overwhelmed then
you become overwhelmed yeah so if you
fix those two things know that you can
find not just one idea you can find
hundreds of ideas and the second thing
is you do have time
the world is under your control the
world does not control you if you change
those two things you are very likely to
succeed I was giving a talk and I asked
somebody what what they love spending on
and she said clothes she said she loves
buying clothes I said and she was so
excited I love just whenever you ask
people their eyes light up and I asked
her what would it look like uh if you
quadrupled your spending and she said I
would have clothes everywhere like all
day long I'd be ordering online I'd be
sending half of them back and I said
where do you shop and she said Topshop
and I said okay so you quadrupled your
spending where would you shop she said
Topshop I just have a lot more
and it was fascinating because when you
ask people what they love spending on
and what if they could spend more what
would they do most people have never
thought about it she had limited herself
into the box of Topshop now I don't know
topshop's perfectly fine that's fine but
I guarantee you if you quadrupled or 10x
you're spending on the thing you love
your money dial you might shop at a
different brand you might even fly to
the factory that makes them and get a
behind the scenes tour as I did when we
went on our honeymoon so why I'm sharing
this is that
so many of us operate in a linear way oh
if I have this thing I like I like
coffee I might get two coffees a day but
what if you actually truly love it you
might go to the coffee factory and bring
your family with you so there's this
whole idea of what you can do with a
rich life and it doesn't just mean more
stuff it could be experiences it could
be security like buying a house in a
place that keeps you safe or staying in
a hotel where you're around things that
are comfortable for you there's so many
different ways to look at a rich life
and most people I want to challenge them
to really think what it would feel like
to spend more on the thing they love of
course if they cut costs mercilessly on
the things they don't I liken my journey
with money to the journey that I took
with Fitness about 10 years ago I
decided to get into get more fit and I
started with a very simple reason which
was pure vanity I was like I want to
look like that and I think vanity can be
a good reason to get started with
something but I think if any of us have
done something that we got good at
whether it be an instrument or
programming or a different language you
might start for one reason what I found
is that I ended up falling in love with
the craft and the discipline to go every
single day and to know that yeah you
might look a certain way but that's
actually a byproduct of all the work
that you've put in every single day and
perfecting that craft
same with money
whereas I used to go after money now I
realize that money is the byproduct of
doing all the right things and I
actually remember this as recently as
six months ago we're on our honeymoon
and I love hotels I keep a list of
hotels that I want to go to and like I
love them and I remember we were staying
at the the last place on our honeymoon
and we were already happy because we're
on our honeymoon and just having the
time of our lives but I remember being
even more happy because I was at this
Dream hotel that I'd been wanting to
stay at for years and I was trying to
figure out why am I so happy even
happier than the Baseline
and what I realized was being able to be
there
with my wife but also be able to be
there and not have to worry about can we
afford this or can we order uh room
service that meant that I had done all
the right things for years I showed up
at work I got a team which is an
amazingly talented team we made the
right decisions we recovered when we
made the wrong ones and now this is the
payoff this is one of the rewards of our
rich life what about online launch your
first launch or your first product maybe
what do you see what are some big red
flags people need to look out for one is
discounting so if you truly built a
product that's amazing why on Earth
would you discount at 50 it makes no
sense second people trying to create
their first product that's a thousand or
two thousand dollars big mistake we
recommend our zero to launch students
start at a 50 product why
because you learn certain things at
fifty dollars at five hundred dollars at
a thousand dollars you learn certain
things about what needs to happen in a
launch what kind of pricing psychology
you're going to encounter what type of
customers are you going to get you will
learn that at 50 but it's different at
500. and so we want our students to go
methodically up the value chain that's
how we went from a 4.95 product to like
twelve thousand dollars we didn't just
jump from a to z you're the CEO of your
business you decide if you want to run a
McDonald's type of business awesome
McDonald's is an amazing company if you
want to run a Louis Vuitton style type
of business where you're focusing on
select customers you can do that as well
don't ever let anyone pressure you into
one decision you are the CEO and you
decide really fast Define a rich life
for people because I think that's going
to be a key component to this whole
discussion well it's different for
everyone my rich life early on was to be
able to go to a restaurant and Order
appetizers because I never did it when I
was a kid like ever we would go and we'd
eat up once every four to six weeks if
we had a coupon and we would like share
two cokes with the whole family and we
would never order appetizers so I was
like I'm gonna do it and then the next
dream for me was to be able to
hop in a taxi if I lived in New York
during the summer without having to take
the train and sweat before a meeting now
my dreams got bigger and there's a
variety of things that are my rich life
but everybody's is different so some
people I have people in my book they're
like I use your book my wife and I
retired at 35 and 36 we drive around in
an RV
I don't want to drive around in an RV
but he and his wife do and I love that
so a rich life is what you define and
when I ask people what's a rich life to
you they usually say two things freedom
which is a very nice word but it's kind
of generic and they say a number usually
a million bucks and I say like Freedom
what is what is that to you and they're
like I want to do whatever I want when I
want and I'm like get specific you want
to order appetizers do you want to do
yoga at 3 pm
and that's where the conversation stops
so if you're watching I want everyone to
think what is your rich life and take it
from the clouds to the street I want to
buy three different Lululemon tank tops
a month because I don't ever want to
have to wear an old one whatever go as
crazy as you want I want to travel for a
month and I want to bring my family with
me great a rich life is different for
everyone but it's about your definition
in my own life there are several things
I just don't care about
um don't have a TV I use a MacBook Air
that's seven years old
I know like I should probably work off a
dual monitor setup I just don't care and
I've lived in the same apartment for 10
years and I've rented and I know the
society tells you that renting is
throwing money away that's not true
um these are things that I just don't
care about but on the other hand
convenience I'll spend essentially
anything
hotels I will spend essentially anything
and there's a few other examples my wife
and I together were coming up with our
own money dials relationships is a big
one for us
so I would encourage everyone to really
take this concept and think about it and
don't stay at the surface level you're
if it's Fitness
like yours
great really think about what that looks
like another woman in DC she was into
fitness too and I said what would your
life look like if you quadruple it she's
like I would be shredded I was like love
it
think big
don't talk yourself out of it so that is
what I've learned about
money dials I see tons of entrepreneurs
they have all their design is amazing
they have the best headshots they get
the coolest funnels they just forgot one
thing they forgot to build something
that people actually want and so you can
have the best photography but if you are
not solving a true problem that people
are saying take my money please take it
then no amount of Art Is Gonna help you
I started off with a lot of self-study I
went to watch at that time the Today
Show or tonight sorry tonight's show
it had a ton of celebrities and if you
watch celebrities they are the absolute
best in the world at public speaking
watch them notice their mannerisms
notice their tonality notice their body
language when they're telling a story
like this versus when they're telling a
story I
like and so I started watching and that
was the first part the second part was I
got lots and lots of practice public
speak is one of those things you can't
learn it just by reading a book or even
watching YouTube videos you gotta get
out there so if you don't have
opportunities to do it like
presentations in class or uh you know
you're speaking on panels or something
where else can you do it who else knows
where else could you find Opportunities
to practice your public speaking
Toastmasters awesome you can create a
book club or join some kind of
organization where you have to go around
and talk about something find a way and
then finally when I got more
intermediate I started getting more
formal training I did a media training
group in New York I hired a speech coach
for my Forefront Chicago speech was my
best speech ever and that was because I
reached the limits of my speaking
ability so I hired a coach so that was
my trajectory but I think the key thing
is there number one you can start with
some self-teaching number two you need
practice you need to take a lot of
swings and then if you get more
intermediate or Advanced you can hire
coaches and things like that I also
think that there are other money lenses
other ways to look at the world we heard
uh in the back from the woman who said
that she loves to spend on convenience
which is my money dial
feel safe feel relief feel luxury and
fortunate
safety is something that we all kind of
intuitively get when it's for someone
else oh we'll spend extra so that our
kids are safe
Never Gonna question that
but when it comes to our own spending we
put back that frugality lens so much of
the time it's been drilled into us by
Society there are other money lenses
there are there's the results uh the
money lens of results I could get a
workout on YouTube
or I can pay a personal trainer for
better and faster results there's pure
there's experience why do you think
people go to a really nice restaurant
right five plus courses The Experience
um there's pure luxury
the sweater is not going to last 10
times more longer than that sweater but
you just want it and so sometimes we
need to I think of it almost like a
musician you want to have the note of
frugality
but you don't want to be a one note
player sometimes frugality is the
perfect note but sometimes there are
other notes you want to put in security
luxury results whatever that your money
lens is
I don't want anyone in this room and
anyone watching to be a one note player
there are different notes to use at
different times I don't like budgets for
several reasons number one they don't
work when you talk to any American and
they know they should keep a budget and
yet they don't and why is that because
number one it makes people feel bad
about themselves and if there's anything
Americans are good at it's avoiding
feeling bad number two they don't know
how much they owe or how much they spend
but they know it's bad and so who's
gonna go through the work of actually
writing down this stuff or opening up
some account and then looking at it they
might do it for one month they may do it
for two but after that it's done and
I've seen this consistently through my
own millions and millions of readers
what I prefer is something that is
similar but very different and that is
instead of looking backwards at what you
spent
look forward and say where do I want my
money to go and so what I do in the book
is I recommend some specific percentages
here's how much you should be saving
here's how much you should be investing
and this one people really love here's
how much you should be spending on
guilt-free spending you want to buy a
leather jacket you want to go out to an
amazing dinner
so I want people to not necessarily Look
Backwards in their spending but actually
look forward and as part of that focus
on the things they love as part of their
rich life that is much more motivational
it also sticks a lot more than every
month looking at what you spent and
feeling bad let's add some context
around your investment desires I think
that one of the mistakes that a lot of
financial people make is they try to
make everything about math hey Tom let
me tell you all the reasons what you
just said is wrong and let's look at the
return rates and you might listen to me
politely but deep down you're like I
don't like what this guy's saying let's
actually start with psychology okay what
you just told me is
hey I like gamification I don't want to
think about it and I have a long long
time Horizon okay let's start there
perfect and you also said something
really important which is you like to
create that's what drives you just
managing what you've got is not exciting
are all those things accurate all right
so here's what bad advice would be and
then here's I think what would be better
advice bad advice would be tell them
sell all that it's all like
crackpot stuff put it in a simple Target
date fund and get on with your life come
on Tom that's what the investment
returns say and you're gonna be like get
the hell out of here better advice would
be hey Tom
it sounds like you want to have some
control over your Investments it sounds
like it actually drives you to see you
know at what price you're purchasing it
but it also sounds like you don't want
to think much about the basic mechanics
so why don't we do something like this
why don't we take 80 90 of your
portfolio and put it in low-cost funds
and take 10 and say this is total play
money in fact you have to play with it
or invest it or spend it in some way and
if it's going to be on nfts or Bitcoin
or whatever great suddenly now you have
a real thesis which is this is long-term
stuff we kind of know the returns there
great I'm going to be safe no matter
what happens but I'm also going to be
making giving room for my psychology my
need and desire to track things and
gamify it and play with it when you ask
people what's your rich life
they often give you very similar answers
I want to do what I want when I want
okay that sounds pretty good what do you
want
and then people get very quiet
it's something we haven't really deeply
thought about another common answer
people give is I want to travel
I think that's awesome where do you want
to go
somewhere in Europe
I want to know the details of your rich
life I want to know where you want to go
when what airline seat you want to fly
in who you want to take with you even
where you want to eat
the details are what makes a rich life
rich
I want to give you a couple of examples
of how unique and personal a rich life
can be to you
one of my readers told me that his goal
was to retire in his 30s with his wife
and to travel around the U.S in an RV
now that's not my rich life I don't want
to go anywhere near an RV
but I love and I admire
they designed their own rich life for
themselves
my rich life's very different when my
wife and I decided that we wanted to
travel more we thought about what would
make it magical
so for example for our honeymoon we went
on a very long extended honeymoon across
the world started in Italy brought our
parents with us because that was a
special thing for us and then after
Italy our parents left we continued on
to Kenya on Safari India and Thailand at
each Place making it our own staying in
beautiful hotels because I love hotels
also eating at local people's houses
going on Food Tours things that made it
unique and special for us
I share this with you because I want you
to know that your rich life is yours
your rich life could be picking up your
son from school every day at 3 pm
it could be buying a thousand dollar
cashmere sweater or it can be traveling
for three months a year
there's no judgment here your rich life
is yours what I want to do is inspire
you to think about the Vivid details of
your rich life and then to craft it to
design it to make it yours so that your
rich life fits you almost like a
handmade glove many people especially in
America are buying things that if you
probe them why they're getting it it
boils down to I want to feel good for a
couple of hours yeah I want to spend
money I don't have yeah to buy things I
don't need to impress people I don't
even know yeah on the other hand though
perfectly okay if you say to yourself
you know what I really want that
yes get it let me show you how to even
dream bigger so I think for this person
what I'm willing to bet is that they are
playing whack-a-mole with their money so
they wake up they start the month oh I'm
motivated I need to save some money I
really should do that and then by the
end they're scrolling Instagram they're
reading their emails with links to stuff
to buy and they buy this and they buy
that and they don't even really care
about it I would rather have them sit
down and say you know what what do I
love stop dreaming small dream big I I
want a leather jacket I'm going to make
this up uh maybe I could get a leather
jacket from Gap dream bigger maybe you
can get an even cooler leather jacket or
something you really love okay great
what's it going to take to get that I'm
going to need to save for X months and
I'm going to discipline myself by
automating the money so I don't have to
log in every day and by the you're
building this muscle of discipline of
automation
and at the end the payoff is you get
that thing you truly loved what a lot of
people might discover which I think
aligns a lot with minimalist philosophy
is
I didn't really even want this leather
jacket yes I think that's ultimately the
message of minimalism is you probably
don't want that and my message is maybe
you did and if you did awesome now you
know the work that it takes to get there
and now you can plan for something even
bigger next time what do you love
spending money on I don't mean like I
mean love you and I intuitively have
something in our lives that when we
spend money on it it excites us makes us
happy and if I asked you what would you
like to spend even more money on
you know it
think about it there are some common
categories that fall under what I call
Money dials and I call Money dials
because you can turn that dial up and
you might even be excited to spend more
on it let me give you a few categories
some of these categories could be eating
out that's one of the most common ones
health and fitness travel convenience
and a variety of other categories so
take a second right now think about what
you would love to spend more money on
okay got it
now I'm going to ask you a few guided
questions I'd like for you to follow
along
what if you could spend two times the
amount of money you currently spend
what would that look and feel like to
you
okay for example if you eat out
every so often what would it look like
and feel like to double your spending on
it
well for most of us the answer is not
much so I'm going to push you a little
bit what if you could quadruple your
spending on that money dial right
turning that dial up 4X
what would it look and feel like
now I want to point something out to you
A lot of people think linearly here you
know for example I remember asking this
question on book tour when I was in
Washington DC and somebody's money dial
was eating out and when I asked him what
would it look like if you could
quadruple your spending his answer was
well I'd probably have to go on a diet
because I'd be eating out four times a
week ha ha ha it's one of those hahaha
jokes Because deep down everybody knows
we're thinking linearly we're thinking
if I quadruple my spending
I have to quadruple the frequency
but that's not true is it
in the DC examples case I asked him
what if you 10xed your spending
what would you do then
and he
sat there for a second and then he said
you know I have a list of every
michelin-starred restaurant in town
and I knew I was getting someone I said
who would you take with you and now it
got very quiet and he said my family I
said why
he said because
they've never been able to afford to go
anyplace like that
this is an example of a money dial
when you quadruple your spending or the
next question what if you 10xed your
spending it doesn't necessarily mean
that you would 10x the frequency yeah
sure if you want to eat out double fine
if you want to buy two times the amount
of clothes great
but think about all the different
Dynamics think multi-dimensionally for
example if you like clothes you might
not just shop at the same place you
might actually level up you might buy
higher quality in fact if you truly 10x
if you turn that money dial all the way
you might take your mom and you might
fly to Italy and get something custom
made for both of you what a magical
experience if you love health and
fitness you might not just work out
twice a week you might actually get a
personal trainer or even fly to India
for a one week Yoga Retreat
now I know that these questions can
sound unusual
because for most of us we've never
thought about spending more on the
things we love we've only been told you
have to spend less
but if you don't have a reason to earn
and save and invest money
and it's no surprise that you're not
motivated to do it
in many ways money can buy you happiness
it can buy you convenience it can buy
you memories it can buy you experiences
and for some people it can also buy you
things that you just like you like a
nice t-shirt fine money can solve that
for you so what I want you to do is to
truly go through this exercise start off
with that thing you love what is it is
it health and fitness is it travel is it
eating out is it convenience and so on
then what if you could 2x your spending
easy not much would change what if you
could Forex your spending and then what
if you could 10 x you were spending what
would it look like what would it feel
like remember I want you to not just
think about frequency think about how it
would make you feel think about what
that experience would be like this is
the beginning of really thinking about
how money can affect your happiness and
craft your rich life the typical advice
that you hear is to shrink and cut back
on everything
but as I've always said there's a limit
to how much you can cut there's no limit
to how much you can earn so there are
really three ways that I talk about in
terms of getting stable and it's the CEO
strategy cut costs we all know the the
flavor but I'll give you a specific
example I had somebody
reach out to me and say ramit my wedding
isn't for like seven or eight months
what do you think I should do
and I said without missing a beat I said
you got to cancel it and as someone who
has planned a large wedding I know how
painful that is to just think of all the
money lost all the planning all the time
but in a time like this money in your
pocket is worth more than money in your
pocket later so money in your pocket now
is worth more than money in your pocket
later that means if you have to cancel
certain things that are going to incur
fees later fine deal with the fees later
but get the money in your pocket that's
C
e earn more we can talk about earning
more in a second but there's a whole
opportunity there to start businesses
and start earning more oh is really
something that a lot of people haven't
thought about right now so whether you
have a job or not you can call up the
companies that you owe money to or you
transact with and you can get some
surprisingly great results for example
your student loan company if you guys
own oh student debt uh if you owe credit
card debt uh if you have a cable bill a
cell phone bill or even a landlord you
pick up the phone and this is what you
say you say
I've been a good customer for three
years covid-19 is making it difficult
for me to be able to pay my bills like I
usually do I'd like to know what options
you have available for me
and my readers have used this script A
lot of them have gotten their payments
paused with no Finance or interest
charges and some of them have even
gotten rent waived so there's a lot of
opportunity you're talking about
possible hundreds or even a thousand
plus dollars with one phone call that is
how you start what I do with my
financial system is I set a Target each
year this is how much money I'm going to
save and invest and those numbers are
aggressive there's that's a lot of money
going hard yeah like every 10 30 yeah so
anywhere between those ranges and we
have folks who what you earn correct
yeah and and then remember whenever I
make any unexpected income let's say I
did a speaking gig or something yeah I
might get myself some I might go out to
dinner but the rest I'm just putting
straight in Investments wow okay so that
money grows aggressively and I also want
to remind everybody especially the
entrepreneurs watching I know you have a
lot of entrepreneurs you wouldn't
believe how many entrepreneur friends I
know who have a good business and they
don't invest at all and that's a huge
mistake what should we be investing in
if you have a good business simple
low-cost Target date funds is a great
way to go entrepreneurs yeah index funds
yeah they get a little too smart for
their own good they say I could just put
that money in my business and I always
say look I'm glad you have a business
that's throwing off tons of cash that's
awesome most businesses don't last 80
years yeah so be smart give yourself a
small Plan B put 5K a month 10K a month
whatever is appropriate for your level
of success
and hey maybe your business does really
well that's awesome but maybe one day
something goes wrong always want to be
prepared you never want to have your
back against the wall so I just want to
encourage everybody whether you're
making 250k or 2.5 million for the high
earners here don't get too smart for
your own good keep investing and saving
if you bring anyone on the show who
tells you what's going to happen in the
stock market they're an idiot and and or
they're lying so I'm not going to do
that nobody knows and you'll find this
in politics and money a lot of people
want to be comforted by essentially a
parental figure somebody who comes in
here and tells you it's all going to be
okay or conversely it's all going to and
they prey on people's weaknesses as to
what's going on the best investors are
humble they know that nobody knows
anything what do we know we know that
over time the market continues to return
approximately seven to eight percent and
that's over 100 plus years
we know that there are always people on
Reddit and Twitter who've got these
fanciful narrations of what's going on
in the world and they all disappear once
the narrative is proved incorrect so
people have been talking about inflation
forever
this is a very low inflation and in fact
even the recent inflation numbers are I
think over 30 of us do to used car
prices okay if you try to Peg your
Investments to macro economics
you will be potentially losing out on
lots of money if you don't build a habit
of Saving right now you're never going
to do it you didn't do it when the
economy was good you're not doing it
when the economy is bad you're never
going to do it so I want everyone
listening to force themselves take
advantage of the situation and really
change your behaviors get that emergency
fund in order yes it will cost you
because you won't be investing right now
and that sucks but if you don't have 12
months that is the price you pay for not
having saved it and it's okay all of us
are operating at different levels we all
have different advantages in society it
doesn't mean that you're being penalized
or that you're morally wrong but I do
believe you should focus on the
emergency fund first invest second I
would like to issue a challenge for
everybody listening all right everybody
listening I call it the 100 challenge
I would like for you
to think about something you love
and I would like for you to spend a
hundred dollars in the next 48 hours
now here are the rules
you're not allowed to spend it on your
kids
pet
you're not allowed to spend on anybody
else it's only for you
and if you have a high net worth
I want you to adjust that number upwards
I spoke to a couple on my podcast this
episode is coming out in just a couple
of weeks
they have
an eight million dollar net worth
and I issued the same challenge to them
they adjusted the numbers upward
so it's up to you the point is I want
you to build the skill of spending
and I want you to write me send me a DM
on Instagram or if you're on my email
newsletter send me an email my email's
all over there I'm on Twitter as well I
want to hear what you did
with your hundred dollar challenge
the point of this is to show yourself
you know what I I'm worth it I can spend
on myself and when I do spend 100 or 500
whatever the number is you choose the
world is not going to end my retirement
is not going to fall off track I can do
it and I can experience
satisfaction happiness convenience
100 that's what I would like to issue
that challenge to everybody listening I
finally boiled these down into what I
call remit's Money Rules always have one
year of emergency fund cash okay fine
you can make it six months or a year
whatever but here's another one never
question spending money on books
appetizers health or donating to a
friend's charity fundraiser each of
those is very meaningful to me because I
didn't grow up being able to afford
appetizers so now if I eat out with a
friend or whoever I say look whatever
you like on the menu just order it and
that feels amazing what does it cost me
an extra 20 bucks but it feels
incredible and then there's some really
big ones anytime I take a flight over
four hours business class or be able to
pay in full for large expenses including
a wedding dream honeymoon or even a
house those are really big rich life
dreams and rules what I would challenge
each person as they think about their
rich life is I would love for them to
say every week I love fresh flowers it
feels a little indulgent to me but it
just makes me feel so good and so I'm
gonna buy fresh flowers for myself every
week beautiful I'll take you what you
know I think that you remember the book
The Emperor has no clothes
I remember learning about money while I
was studying human behavior in
Psychology and I remember a moment where
I said the emperor has no clothes all
this advice that people give us about
money like cut back on lattes I
intuitively just said I don't want to do
that I don't want to live a life where
I'm cutting back on three dollar
expenses and tracking every single penny
for my entire life I found a budget yeah
and like living a life of scarcity oh I
can't spend money on lattes I can't go
out I can't I just got to go in a cave
and save money for 80 years and maybe I
can live life that I didn't want to live
like that and I looked around and none
of my friends did either and here we are
beautiful Manhattan a lot of people here
don't want to live like that so I wanted
to live in a way that allowed me to say
I want to go out and buy a round of
drinks for my friends I want to spend on
the things I love and I don't want to be
sitting there typing in Excel every
single day for three hours my rich life
is to set up my systems automate them so
that they run beautifully and then get
off my chair and live outside the
spreadsheet that's my rich life and so I
started integrating psychology and money
and it grew and it grew and now it's got
millions of readers and here I am this
is more the art of it the art of it is
setting dreams that are things you
actually want and a rich life you know
let me tell you what a rich life is a
rich life can be picking up your
daughter from school every day at 3 pm
that could be a rich life for you a rich
life could be buying a one thousand five
hundred dollar coat
a rich life could be traveling two
months a year Money Matters of course
money is a small but important part of a
rich life but if you ask people
listening right now what is your rich
life you'll often find that they haven't
really thought about it it's too
intimidating it's too scary and deep
down they don't believe they can achieve
it so they say words like travel and I
want to get healthier and you know I'd
like to clean my garage out all fine you
should probably clean your garage out
I've seen some of these garages they're
absolutely atrocious that's adult fine
dude yeah no judging however
you know when it comes to money so much
of it is negative people think about
money they've been warned of all the
things that can go wrong oh you better
increase your savings rate oh don't do
this and what I'm here to talk about is
what you can do with your money why
money should be a source of joy and
adventure and memorability that is much
more inspiring and much more likely to
cause a real change in your life you
know I teach people how to negotiate
their salaries and how to negotiate fees
from their credit cards and bank
accounts so rent is just a natural one
because for most people rent is their
largest single expense it's a high
leverage point
and uh this is just a typical way that
Americans believe that
um they simply have to accept what's
handed to them right oh my bank leverage
the 37 late fee on them well your bank
works for you why don't you call them up
and ask for them to negotiate that and
they will chapter one of my book well I
did the same thing with Rhett
you don't simply accept a rent increase
you want to understand the context
around it so my building was quite
aggressive they would always try to
raise rent of course they would it's a
capitalist system of course they're
going to try to maximize their profit I
get that no hard feelings but you need
to know that I'm going to maximize my
opportunity as well so I would always
have my eye on articles on New York City
rent and I would just file them away you
know I would tag them and then when time
came for my lease
we'd have a meeting
and they would say something like we
want to raise your rent X dollars and I
would say
so first I would understand the power
Dynamic at a time like this right now
tenants have very low power okay very
low so you try to negotiate your rent
you have low power because there's a
housing shortage and there's more demand
that's why prices are going up simple
supply and demand
sometimes especially during the 10 plus
years I lived in New York
prices were going down so I would go in
there and I would use my briefcase
technique and that is a whole procedure
of how you can present to clients or a
boss and you can negotiate ten twenty
thirty thousand dollar raises and I
would say I appreciate you tell me where
you came up with that number and they
would give me some and I would
say okay thanks now let me show you my
research and I would show them that the
comps in the neighborhood were down you
know six percent sometimes or flat and I
would say so that rent increase isn't
going to work for me in fact I would
like to discuss a decrease now
landlords will Almost Never decrease
your rent
they play lots of games if they decrease
it it has to show so what they would do
instead they would say we'll give you a
couple of months free
I said great I will take it and of
course I took that money
and I floated through my chapter 5
automation system some of it got
invested some of it got saved and some
of it got spent on guilt-free spending
over 10 years this is going to shock
people over 10 years I essentially paid
the same amount in red at the beginning
and at the end
let me say that again sounds incredible
it's crazy my rent went up and down and
that is how rent Works everybody listen
rent does not just go up rent is subject
to the laws of supply and demand just
like chicken so if chicken prices go up
and down and gas prices go up and down
so does housing the key is you have to
ask my rent went up sometimes and I
accepted it you know I would try but
negotiation is a dance and sometimes it
stayed flat and that was fine and
sometimes it went down and I took the
win over the course of 10 years it went
up and down up and down but essentially
it ended up
with a slight increase basically flat
what kind of people do I want to
surround myself notice I'm not even at
the point of recommending specific
people to follow that's way later
what do I want to follow
and you might and these by the way Remy
not to cut you off but I'm also thinking
these are phenomenal values-based
conversations for couples to have right
I mean if you're playing with anybody
this year holy crap is this a phenomenal
uh dinner with wine conversation if it's
Cheryl and I that this is powerful stuff
totally totally it's so much richer when
you can bring in your loved ones to this
conversation and it's such a beautiful
thing to be able to say you know what
I I realized that I think I need to make
a change and my wish my dream would be
that you come along with me and we do
this as partners but I really need your
help oh my God has your spouse or your
partner ever heard you say that wow
that's so incredibly connective so you
start making a list of what you do want
to surround yourself with and I think
this is where people feel ashamed
they might you know for me I want to
surround myself with beautiful things I
like Beauty and I like simplicity so I'm
looking at you know like a Japanese
Monastery I want pictures of that when I
open up certain places that I follow I
want beautiful design handmade Pottery
now for a lot of people that feel
shameful to say it feels kind of
frivolous
I don't care that's what I want for you
it might be I want to improve my fitness
or I want to become more adventurous and
spontaneous awesome now you've written
these values down and finally and
finally and finally step three is you
can go out and seek some of those people
out that's how I would do it you know
what every time I ask people their rich
life and I probe their first answers are
never what we ultimately settle on but
as we start talking about it and we
spend a lot of time really probing and
pushing why that well what if you
dreamed a little bigger and they also
smile the whole time because no one has
ever asked him what is your rich life
and really asked him why
never so usually if it's something like
a handbag right something tangible
most people start off by saying like
this well I know I mean I guess I'd like
a purse it doesn't have to be like the
fanciest purse but you know I'd like
this handbag and like maybe once every
decade it could be like a nice one and I
go
what if it was every year
and what if it was that brand the the
most beautiful version of it
and their eyes light up because no one
has ever talked to them about the thing
that deep down they love what I call
their money dial instead it's kind of
seen as frivolous particularly things
like handbags which I don't agree with I
think you could buy a beautiful handbag
for the craftsmanship for the
functionality or just because you want
it for those people who can't see Remy
right now he's winking at me so I know
what to get you for Christmas thank you
very much please continue
and you know I'm hoping as I'm asking
these questions that their partner is
seeing and can model this because you'll
usually find that when one partner is
nervous because they think that it's
frivolous that there's a reason for that
that their partner has said something
multiple times in the past like well why
do you don't need a handbag like that
you don't need that kind of car and yeah
you don't need it but we're here talking
about your rich life to start we're
going to get to the spreadsheet stuff
we're going to get to your spending plan
but let's just start off with your
vision of what a rich life is that is
exciting the first thing you can do is
to this is a really hard exercise
because you have to examine inside and
people find it very hard to examine what
is invisible to themselves so what I
like to do is to recommend they look at
somebody else somebody else who they
admire and is successful let's take you
so we're talking about Jim what does Jim
do that is different than what I do and
then we dig deeper why does he do it why
did Jim move from the west coast to the
east coast now I don't know I'm just
analyzing this but I can come up with
three reasons and I'm probably within 80
accuracy why does Jim wear this t-shirt
why does he dress this way where does he
eat now of course you might not know
what Jim does on a day-to-day basis but
you might pick someone in your community
and when you start to do that you go
from a place of what I call
disparagement to curiosity this is a
critical thing
it's really easy for people to disparage
Someone I used to do it when I was in my
early 20s I would walk on a plane all
the people were sitting in business
class I'd walk past them to the back and
you judge I would totally judge him I
was like why would they spend all that
extra money three times as much for what
we're all getting to the same place haha
they're so stupid
it's very funny how
in our puritanical Society
people feel Superior because they save
more money or because they don't spend
as much when in reality instead of
disparaging other people who maybe eat
at a nice restaurant or take a certain
type of trip it would be much better to
say why do they do that they if they can
afford to be sitting in business class
what's going on that would make them
want to spend three or four times the
price what do they know that I don't
know and if I had done that in my 20s I
would have been way more open-minded
instead I was like oh so dumb I felt
superior but that's not the right way to
go to bust your own invisible scripts
you got to be curious about why other
people are doing what they do my real
question is not what kind of
multi-family real estate you gonna buy
my question is what are you going to do
with your money and if you can't answer
that in a hypothetical scenario then I
guarantee you have no answer to what
you're going to do with your own
portfolio those people this is what
they're going to do they're gonna save
they're gonna have an enviable savings
rate thirty percent forty percent
they're going to recalculate their Monte
Carlo simulation 35 times a month
they're going to post about it on fat
fire and other fire forums and they're
going to judge everybody who has less
than a 32 savings rate because oh my God
financial literacy is out of control in
America and then they're going to move
to Florida get some leathery skin and
die
that's the life that's it and I say
where did you eat
who did you take with you what did you
go skydiving once or did you buy a nice
shirt something did you donate
generously you know create a rule for
yourself I'm only donating 30 percent
sorry I'm only tipping 30 or higher what
are you gonna do with your money and uh
the answers are very lackluster I I want
to share one more example Joe because
this one also drove me crazy bring it
because you're not at all passionate
about this so bring it I I want to
finally see some passion yeah I know
it's uh
so there's this guy uh on a forum who is
Young he's like 28 or 30 years old and
he has a huge net worth it was something
like uh 12 million dollars okay some guy
sold a company or whatever
and his question was where should I live
to minimize taxes
okay now everybody just listen right now
first of all I know that there are
approximately three topics we can talk
about where everyone's gonna get mad and
also everyone doesn't know what they're
talking about number one is taxes number
two is tipping number three is the price
of weddings I've written about them all
just Google ramit seiti and any of those
words
so this guy's 12 million dollars
do you understand how much a 30 year old
is going to have if they have 12 million
dollars at that age what hundreds of
millions of dollars you physically
cannot spend that kind of money it's
impossible okay
and he's optimizing for where he can
minimize his taxes
now if the guy wants to live in Florida
or Dallas Texas God bless I love it if
you if that's your rich life do it I I
love it
but I know it's not I know that this
person who could live in any city in the
world that's not his rich life because
the first question he's asking is how do
I minimize my taxes now let's zoom out I
don't want to judge just this person for
Texas although I am I want to talk about
why do we think this way and the answer
is we only have one note that we all
play and that is how little can I pay it
doesn't matter whether the amount is
you know ten thousand dollars that you
save or a much larger amount invariably
if you've been saving and or investing
for a while you will ultimately have an
amount where you have to decide what to
do with it and most of us spend our
entire lives focusing on just the saving
part but I think probably every single
one of us has a parent or a relative or
somebody older than us who does not know
how to enjoy their money and they still
drive around town to save money on gas
and you say look you've got enough what
are you gonna do with it and then
ultimately they will say something like
well I guess I'll just give it to my
kids your kids don't want the money they
want you to have a good life they want
you to spend it on the things you love
and so that's why I'm so passionate
about this In fairness some of the kids
want the money
but a lot of kids also want their
parents to have a grip okay I did not
make an allowance for those people
they're like counting the clock oh
that's sad so you know I have found that
you cannot tell people who struggle with
spending money hey guys you really need
to spend more money it's just it goes in
one ear and out the other it's not even
a factor in their life that's why I
spend so much time saying what's your
rich life it's very much like the same
you can't tell someone who loves
chocolate cake cut out the chocolate
cake instead we say hey let's add a
little bit more delicious chicken let's
add some really good asparagus yeah you
still want the chocolate cake cool but
it's probably gonna just naturally
become a little bit less of a part on
the plate so when I when I talk about
their rich life when I understand the
texture the color I don't want them to
say travel
I want them to say I'm going to
Indonesia for four weeks with my
beautiful wife we're gonna sit in seat
2A or 2D and this is where we're going
to stay and this is what we're gonna do
and we're even gonna have a food tour
and we're gonna do this and that now
it's Vivid vivid enough that they get
excited about it I also use the stick
where I say okay right now you're
38 years old this was a couple that I
spoke to and I said by my calculations
by the time you're in your 60s you will
have over 26 million dollars
when are you going to start spending
your money
and they looked at each other and he
goes well probably when I retire
and I just point blank said to him I
don't believe you do you believe him and
the wife said no I don't believe of
course I don't believe you can't even
spend his money right now
and so what I encouraged them and what I
showed them was
would you rather end up at 60 with some
amount of money or would you rather end
up at 60 with just a little bit less
money but a lifetime worth of experience
ultimately when I'm speaking to people
like this who find it difficult they're
just afraid afraid that they'll lose it
all and as I probed him you know what he
told me his dad had lost all of his
money late in life
so you often find these family
challenges that they cannot escape from
how did he lose his money do you
remember how did his dad who's in
another country and he made a series of
bad Investments and bad deals and lost
it all so they've constantly lived with
this fear as by the way all of us do
based on the cues we were raised with
that you know I could lose it all or
that I'll never be rich or that the rich
are all evil and those are some of those
invisible scripts that we have to work
through if we want to work with our
partner together towards a rich life Dan
Kennedy has this beautiful quote that I
love he says why spend less when you can
spend more why spend less when you can
spend more it totally blows people's
mind but we all intuitively have an area
where we just get it if you have
children
and I said to you why don't you just
optimize and get the cheapest baby food
and the cheapest I they'd be like you
this crazy
so why is it different for ourselves why
do we talk ourselves out of that and
that is the thing that I want people to
do with money lenses is to say you know
what it's okay to just play with the
concepts in your mind and then when you
find something you love go and spend
just once and see what it feels like I
had a woman I was speaking to yesterday
she said that when she took a trip to
London recently her her first money lens
was cost and so she saved money she got
sort of these seats that were the
cheapest she got to the hotel she was
hungry everything was closed she called
downstairs closed so she remembers that
trip being hungry tired cramped all
costs the next time she took a trip she
started asking herself a question what
would it take to make this a spectacular
experience so she was using the
experience money lens okay she said it
cost her a little bit more like a couple
hundred bucks more but this time she
planned better she spent two or three
hours planning her seat she had a list
of restaurants ready to go she got to
her place she was refreshed she felt
great and now the whole memory of that
second trip is as she put it spectacular
so it doesn't have to cost a lot but you
have to be intentional about what money
lenders
I started the blog while I was in
college I started it in 2004 because and
it wasn't some burst of Genius it was
that I was trying to teach my friends
about personal finance and
I would sit there and listen at the
dining halls and they'd be complaining
about my overdraft fee or something
and I would say hey why don't you come
take my free one-hour class
and they said that sounds awesome and
then they would never show up yeah so
what I learned later is that people
don't really want to go to events about
money makes them feel bad about
themselves you also don't really want to
learn from your friends because your
friend is your friend you go out
drinking with it's not your friend you
listen to about asset allocation right
and also I had a lot to learn myself I
was talking about Banking and budgeting
which college kids don't care about
so that didn't work I did that for a
year and a half it's very frustrating I
would show up nobody would come
but I just felt like I had something
that the world needed to hear and I just
said let me start a blog maybe I'll
start it and these lazy college kids
will read it from their dorm room and
that turned out to be exactly right
people liked to read someone like them
instead of lecturing them I would just
talk and I would talk to them about all
the things that people like you and I
care about we got that cheap friend who
never puts in a tip when we go out to
eat like all these things that are just
day-to-day real life and over time that
blog grew and grew and that eventually
turned into a business so when was The
Tipping point where you decided okay I'm
going to focus on the Blog full time
well that was something I thought about
a lot because at a certain point the
blog was kind of starting to grow and
there was you know like a hundred
thousand monthly readers and then 150
and I started getting people emailing me
and it started to get into this thing
that I realized was a little bigger than
I had ever imagined but I told myself
I'm working at PB Wiki I'm committed and
so the the mental uh exercise that I ran
with myself was I'm not even going to
think about doing this full-time until
my blog generates more income than my
full-time job for four months in a row
oh wow okay and it like it would happen
one month and then it would stop so I
had to reset so it kind of just allowed
me to put that thing out of my mind
instead of constantly agonizing over it
and finally it started to actually
happen consistently and consistently
that didn't mean I just jump ship I then
I could start to actually think about it
because I knew that the financial
concern was not that
if you take somebody and you just talk I
do this a lot they'll be at one of my
talks or they are on my newsletter or
following me on Instagram and uh I'll
give you an amazing example that just
happened recently I had a woman who
wrote me and she said ramit can you help
me convince my husband not to waste
money and I go okay what what's going on
she goes he spends so much money on iced
tea and I was like here we go I go how
much money and she goes he buys iced tea
20 times a month like almost every day I
said how much is this iced tea she said
it's a dollar fifty each time so in my
head I'm like this is insane like why
are we even talking about this but I
knew there's something here so I want to
unpack it I said out of curiosity what's
your household income
no response for 20 minutes okay and then
finally she comes back she goes I'm not
comfortable sharing that
I said just give me a wrench okay what
do you think her her and her husband's
household incomings I know the story I I
would have guessed otherwise 80
000 and 100 000 like a nice
six hundred thousand and the this is a
perfect example like rationally and
logically we should literally not be
talking about this because it's a
rounding error but
there's something going on in her belief
system that made her fixate on iced tea
and So for anybody whether it's iced tea
or whether it's you know lattes is a
classic example everybody tells you not
to spend money I'm like that's the worst
advice ever buy as many lattes as you
want or some people they just love for
example clothes right I like clothes
they love it but everybody around them
has told them things like that's shallow
that's a waste of money you should
invest in your Roth IRA and so what do
they do all of us we're torn apart
because we live in a paradoxical society
that is both puritanical telling us we
should Retreat into a cave and do
nothing but then we go on Instagram and
everyone's in Bora Bora it's ridiculous
and so what do we do we just buy
everything and then we feel guilty it's
the worst possible response so what I do
is first I say what do you love spending
money on love and nobody talks about
this they always say oh let me see your
budget you're overspinning and
everyone's just like ah forget this I'll
never come on here and berate someone
for their spending because I've seen it
all when they talk about what they love
then I say what would it feel like to be
able to spend two times or four times as
much on them people have never thought
like that
then once we start from a place of
aspiration of what do we want let's work
through the mechanics of how to get
there be
I want to celebrate you most
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Grant Cardone
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there if you've got a
thousand dollars I would like just keep
investing yourself until you got another
thousand and then invest in yourself you
should start making money faster you
know there's things I bought that I
didn't get a return on right away but I
didn't quit investing in a course or a
workshop